conectamos con Carlos verísimo Él es
analista político de política exterior y
experto en temas de Estados Unidos
Carlos Gracias a usted y expliquémosle a
la audiencia Qué es el tratado New
starts y Qué implicaciones tiene el
hecho de que Rusia suspenda su
participación en este importante pacto
sobre control de armas nucleares
Buenos días Ángela realmente es un es
uno de los tratados más importantes que
han firmado las dos potencias más
nucleares del mundo se considera que más
de un 90% de los armamentos nucleares
están entre los dos países Estados
Unidos y Rusia en este caso fue claro el
presidente Putin no se retiran los
suspenden él lo había renovado en el año
2021 con una llamada telefónica entre
Valle de Miguel hasta el año 2026 ya
había anunciado Rusia que en el 2026 no
iba a renovarlo más en este caso lo que
está ocurriendo es algo que ya estaba
anunciado el departamento de estado de
Estados Unidos ya había dicho que en el
agosto del año pasado los rusos no
habían dejado hacer una de las 18
visitas obligatorias que tienen el New
stark para hacer durante cada uno de los
años del acuerdo
Carlos pero Putin Además ella ha puesto
la opción de las armas nucleares sobre
la mesa en repetidas oportunidades puede
ser esta una nueva amenaza velada del
kremli en el discurso de Putin
indudablemente que sí Ángeles muy buena
pregunta el discurso fue un discurso
plagado de nacionalismo de expresiones
un tanto duras para el mundo occidental
de pedofilia gays totalitarios y un
anuncio que era normal de poder hacerse
En definitiva los dos países han entrado
una escalada retórica importante que
podría llevar a una situación más
complicada No no tenemos que sacarnos de
la visión de que biden visitando quien
también hizo una jugada muy fuerte y de
alguna forma tenemos que esperar alguna
reacción la reacción de Putin hace una
de reacción acorde a lo que se está
dando y fundamentalmente de unificación
de toda Rusia hay que ver que esto
también está enmarcado en el aniversario
de la guerra de una guerra que Ellos
pensaban ganar en quince días y que
realmente no sabemos qué pasa
internamente pero la población ya debe
estar cansada de una guerra que en vez
de ser Relámpago ha sido una guerra de
desgastes y que ha llevado un costo muy
importante hacia la nación rusa y
finalmente Estados Unidos tilda la
decisión de irresponsable Y dice estar
abierto al diálogo y desde la otan
también invitan a moscúa que reconsidere
existe posibilidad para ese diálogo
en este momento me parece que no el
sentido del discurso es un sentido
totalmente nacionalista como lo dije Y
de alguna forma tuvo que marcar algún
tipo de ápice en base a las situaciones
que se le habían dado en el pasado el
mundo tiene que estar muy preocupado con
lo que está pasando No solo porque el
desarme o la desactivación el pasar de
lo que se considera hoy dos mil ojivas
nucleares que es la que tiene Rusia a
1550 y de la misma forma Estados Unidos
pasar también a 1550 es muy importante
para las dos naciones como para el mundo
en sí el parar con la guerra
la escalar armamentista que se está
dando antes de de un prólogo de guerra
es algo interesante y el y el mundo
nuclear es algo que el mundo que tenemos
que intentar abandonar el mundo no puede
seguir creciendo nuclearmente en cuanto
armamento y más en estos en